à peine plus de vingt jours après son
départ de la maison blanche donald trump
fait toujours recette
alors que le procès en destitution de
l'ancien président occupe tous les
esprits de nombreux partisans du
milliardaire américain se sont retrouvés
lors d'un salon des armes à feu en plein
coeur de la virginie occidentale un état
de près de deux millions d'habitants
presque entièrement acquis au candidat
républicain qui a obtenu plus de 68% des
voix lors de la présidentielle de
novembre pour ses supporters pas de
doute ce procès est inutile c'est une
mauvaise chose
il a quitté son poste pourquoi vouloir
le destituer la destitution consiste à
le démettre de ses fonctions il est déjà
parti
peu importe que vous croyez que
l'élection était épaulé ou non il n'est
plus en fonction il est parti il ya une
telle haine envers donald trump que je
pense qu énormément de gens ont dit peu
importe ce qu'il en coûte pour contrôler
ou indifférents nous devons sortir de
cette situation dans une amérique
fracturé par les divisions ou plus de 74
millions d'électeurs votaient pour
desalle trump la crainte d'un
embrasement du pays restent vives
je suis très inquiet de la direction que
prend le pays
si on continue à aller sur cette voie
ils vont conduire les gens dans une
guerre civile guerre civile un terme
fort qui fait directement écho à
l'envahissement du capitole par
plusieurs milliers de partisans de
l'homme d'affaires américain il y à un
peu plus d'un mois
un épisode qui prouve l'influencent du
désormais ex-président sur ses électeurs
mis aussi sur une partie des élus
républicains
mais ce procès pour mise en accusation
qui va avoir lieu la semaine prochaine
est un véritable cirque c'est un circuit
qui permet aux entreprises médiatiques
d'obtenir beaucoup de clips beaucoup de
vues et de vendre des plages de
publicité et vous savez quoi c'est aussi
assez dégoûtant
tout le monde ici sait qu'il n'a pas
provoqué cette attaque contre le
capitole oui moi ni aucun répit
du procès de donald trump est incertaine
nombreux sont ses supporters à ne pas
douter de son innocence
un pan de l'amérique que joe biden aura
le plus grand mal à rallier à sa cause